thank you all for being here my name is
shannon rose mcauliffe i'm the manager
of the student arts programs at mit
and we're all here today to kick off the
2020 2021
15k creative arts competition i'm really
excited to
introduce everybody we have team
elements who are our 15k
first place winners last year we've got
michael and maria
i have ellen shakespeare from 2018 her
venture is called
space us and then i've got a fantastic
mentors near hindi and john corbier
also joining to offer some of their
perspectives about what it's like to
help these
ventures facilitate their success
let's start by going around everybody
give me a minute long
intro and a brief overview of your
venture we'll start with
elements hi everyone i'm maria
i'm architect i'm an architect by
training and i recently graduated from
mit from a masters of science in
architecture studies
and i'm co-founder of elements so
elements is design learning in a box
we're developing
at home art and design curriculum for
students ages 10 to 14
and we're hoping to expand access to
design education by putting creative
curriculum
in the hands of students around the
world and the other co-founder is
michael hey everyone it's good to see
you this sunday my name is michael
stradley i'm also an architect by
training
i just finished the master of science
also in architectural design at mit
and the way elements started maria and i
partnered up in the
fall of 2019 and we were we were kind of
guests teaching a small design seminar
looking
experimental teaching methods and
architecture and
the the idea felt strong our partnership
built strong and so we built
that kind of roush collaboration into
elements we've been working on that ever
since
excellent thank you both for that
introduction why don't we pop over to
ellen next
hey thanks shannon um and thanks for the
invitation to be here it's a pleasure
um my name is ellen and about three
years ago my co-founder
stephanie and i started our venture
which is called space s
and space sus works with artists and
property owners
to turn underused urban space whether
that's
a vacant storefront or perhaps a
neglected park in a neighborhood
into spaces for communities to come
together and for
artists and their work to be showcased
and we do this
because we believe that when artists
have space in the city
everybody benefits um and stephanie and
i
um you know we started it as
architecture students
um at mit um you know it was as simple
as walking down mass ave on the way to
studio every morning and seeing these
vacant storefronts along
you know in central square and kindle
and thinking there's got to be a better
a better way to use these spaces and um
simultaneously knowing that
the city of boston and cities elsewhere
continuously need space for artists and
so
you know for the last three and a half
years we've been working on doing that
sort of matching these spaces
with artists and small businesses and
entrepreneurs who need the space to
um to grow and thrive in the city um
obviously that's
uh a strange uh thing to be working on
during covid
you know this idea of bringing people
together indoors is something that you
know makes everybody kind of cringe
these days
rightly so um so recently we've been
expanding the kinds of places that we
work as well so working outdoors with
communities
in parks and parking lots even
this past summer we put together a fair
for the city of boston that used these
sort of more socially distant and safe
sites to um
to continue to celebrate local art
that's excellent thank you so much i
also look forward to hearing a little
bit more about that as we continue with
the panel
um next up we have near hindi hi
everyone
good afternoon from madrid spain my name
is neil i'm coming from original
background in entrepreneurial business
entrepreneurial
background started few companies today i
always say i kind of combine to my
greatest passion
art and entrepreneurship i'm the founder
of the altean
and what i do with reality and is
basically i take art
as a way of thinking because for me art
is always about the mindset
it's not about the object and i help
business organization to bring
out more as a way of thinking into
specifically the innovation
processes in business organizations
and thanks shannon for inviting me to be
here
it's a pleasure having you here and next
up we'll have our last introduction from
john hi everyone
um thanks so much for having me my name
is john corbier i run
a animation design studio in toronto
canada called thought cafe
as well as a technology experiential
company called future talk
we focus primarily on factual content
cause-based
information spreading essentially and
really
have been pushing the boundaries in how
we use uh
augmented reality and virtual reality
technologies to sort of
spread important messages and help
people especially in sort of the
compassion realm
understand um social and political
issues
excellent thank you all so much um now
we're going to get into a slightly
deeper dive about each of your ventures
and experiences
and how they've related to different
aspects that we try to promote in the
15k
so first up for michael and maria i
would love to hear an
update about your progress since may um
and if you can discuss things like the
ramp
project that we did with arts at mit and
how your testing is going that would be
great
sure absolutely and it made feels like a
lifetime ago but
since then we've been we've kept
ourselves pretty busy um
we just concluded this program that you
referenced called ramp
like all good things at mit it's an
acronym it stands for remote art making
pilot
and so this was a six week kind of
experimental art and design studio that
elements ran
in collaboration with mit student art
association
so just following the 15k competition
the student art association reached out
to us they had the same problems
everyone who's teaching right now
we need to do this remotely we want to
support the robust
student art community at mit how do we
do this when we're all distributed over
the summer
so we worked closely with them and we
developed this six-week pilot program it
was kind of unglamorous and
involved packing up boxes with art
materials shipping them to people
all around the country and then meeting
once a week for a few hours to discuss
and critique one another's creative work
um the goal the goal of ramp for us
in addition to doing some meaningful
teaching was that it gave us
the opportunity to pilot a few prototype
ideas that we have
and get user feedback from both
undergraduate and graduate students at
mit
so we specifically we tested three
pieces of curriculum that we hope to
develop
over the coming 12 months those are
going to become products from live
release
the first was curriculum about color
material and
pigment formulation people are taking
objects from the world
turning them into paint the second was a
kit that dealt with cyanotype and
photography without the camera
and the third was a curriculum that
looked at rule-based and generative
drawing systems
yes and currently we're working on
building a pre-launch prototype
which will be made available to a
limited audience this
winter so it's one of the kits that
michael mentioned it's the cyanotype and
photographic
experiment kit and it explores the
like the historical photographic
technique of cyanotype
which allows students to produce
photographs without a camera
using only and sunlight and this kit
will include light-sensitive cyanotype
sheets
as well as a series of design challenges
and historical reference
and a range of materials that will help
the students explore and experiments
with
with this technique that sounds
fantastic
i have to throw this shameless plug if
this sounds compelling to you or you
have a young person
in your family or in your kind of orbit
we hope to get these available
before the holidays so we'll put the
link in the chat if you sign up with
your email we'll let you know
just as soon as we're finished working
on it excellent
i'm also i neglected to introduce my
fantastic
co-host his name is theo fields i
introduced him in the beginning of the
last session but i know that we've had
some new people join us
so theo is my co-moderator and is also
going to be asking some questions to
everybody
yes thanks for the uh the warm intro um
some questions for
ellen aka the spacex team here
um so you mentioned having uh outposts
in new york city
and also kind of a move to pivot your
business model a little bit away from
indoor spaces more towards outdoor
spaces
safe collective gathering who have been
your kind of key partners in that and
what have been
the steps that have been made that
successful and viable
oh i think you are on youtube
ah yes classic um thanks for the
thoughtful question
um i think you know creative reframe
earlier mentioned that nobody does
this type of work alone and that is very
much true in our case there's a
constellation of
of partnerships and resources we rely on
every day
i mean um not the least of which are
folks that you mentor
or that you meet rather through
organizations and competitions like this
truly we are still in touch with mentors
that we met through this very
competition
um we email them constantly for
big big asks and little asks um
and um so there's mentors that we keep
in touch with who
who provide us with resources and
insight there
are folks in the city that have been
particularly essential for us you know
working in the real world
um you know in physical space often
requires us to think about things like
permitting licensing how high can a
banner be
et cetera et cetera um and we've found a
lot of great resources even um just
right in boston
um i suppose i'll give like a quick
shout out to a group called the mayor's
office of new urban mechanics
a division of the mayor's office that is
specifically focused on sort of r
d in the city of boston perhaps
applicable to many teams
these are folks who are really
interested in testing and experimenting
in the city of boston and best
of all they know exactly who to put you
in touch with if there's a specific
um division of the city that might be
applicable to what you're working on so
they've been a huge resource for us and
then i think lastly and maybe most
importantly
our customers um you know we work with
landlords and we work with artists
and talking to them constantly has
provided us with the kind of
um invaluable insight about what our
next step should be you know it's
stephanie and i working full time at
spaceus but we could
go around in circles for hours you know
um
validating one one move or the other and
then you know questioning ourselves but
the clarity that we find when we just
pick up the phone and talk to somebody
who's known us from the beginning
who we've worked with from the beginning
and who is you know out there in the
world
experiencing a reality that is unique to
them and unique to them as a customer of
ours
that has been illuminating so whether
it's through surveys or just picking up
the phone and talking to people
are you comfortable going inside of
spaces yet no like what does that mean
what would you be comfortable with
um and just having a um a landscape of
folks that you can call
and get their feedback on has been
essential for us as we've like both
continued to
operate in boston and look elsewhere as
well
fantastic i think there's a great
takeaway for students which is uh real
customer research
right real customer conversations is
crucial
um speaking of students in the
competition um near and john you guys
have both mentioned
uh mentored students in this competition
before
um we were curious how kind of fully
developed are some of the ideas when you
first encounter them or when you first
encounter the student teams and what
is the most impactful in helping them
kind of refine
reform those ideas as they go through
the competition
john john you want to go first you want
me to go
i can uh why don't you go ahead first
i'll go right after okay
great um so i'll tell you something i
mean
we keep mentioning it but i think one of
the most important thing is the
the team and i always say that i prefer
an a team with a big idea
than a b team with an a idea because the
atm will know how to turn around
an idea and the nature of startup is
that you change on a constant basis so
you have to be agile and flexible
changing and other things that
i kind of what i try to do at least with
the teams that i
mentor is that to really push them into
the validation
phase often we have and a startup is
basically
a bunch of assumptions that you need to
validate and i always encourage them
to leave the building what they say
don't don't stick to the sovereign i
think and just mention it
having a meaningful conversations with
with a customer potential customer is
super
super important in order to validate a
problem
because at the end i tell them you don't
want to find yourself in
sys what we call solution in search of a
problem
you want to really make sure that not
only that you have idea that you have an
idea for the problem that you actually
discover and i think that the teams that
actually go outside of the comfort zone
and
do outside go outside from the building
and do
speaking to customers those are the ones
that actually able to
make the progress in the a competition
um and yeah and what i again what i try
to do as a mentor is
not to provide an answer but rather
asking questions to kind of
guide them through questions and
challenge what they say or challenge
what they think
and one of the exercises that i ask my
teams to do
is to actually think about everything
that can go wrong with your startup
and try to think how are you going to
tackle it because in the world of
startup everything that can go
wrong most likely will go wrong so
that's kind of my
perspective
that was fantastic
um i can give i can give a little i'll
give a little short
thing as well um i think one of the most
important things when you guys are
coming up with these
ideas is is like to share it and share
it with a lot of people there's
we we get really caught up with holding
ideas really close to our hearts and
being afraid that if we share it with
someone they might take it from us so
they might
do it quicker but the reality is is
there's probably dozens
um if not hundreds of people that are
coming to the same conclusions that
you're coming to
at the same time and the only way
to sort of win this race is to do it as
a relay with a team
and to be really really confident about
that team but to not
hold things in so so test with as many
people as possible talk to people about
it
um it's still going to be you know your
idea and your baby
you know try to solve a common problem a
simple problem not a super complex one
especially for this competition
because you're just gonna it's gonna be
very difficult you're gonna run out of
time and you want something that
is simple but iterative that you can
really iterate on
um think about you know areas that give
people anxieties how you can solve those
sort of things
that that kind of stuff is becoming
really really important right now in
in the environment that we're finding
ourselves in so i think you guys should
really focus
on that and then you know don't
necessarily focus on something that
you're
good at obviously you should do
something an area that you're good at
but it's
it's too easy to be sort of uh to get
tunnel vision to be caught up in this
like
great idea about something that you
already know a lot about and something
that you're already good at
but generally that's not always going to
end up being
the best idea that you may be able to
come up with sometimes
the idea you least expected will come up
so you have to be willing to
have a lot of ideas be willing to you
know throw them out quickly and iterate
and sort of let the process guide you
um like like an ocean swell would guide
you you know control your ship
um set a destination but know that that
the pathway there isn't going to
necessarily be exactly what you expected
um so yeah avoid tunnel vision at all
costs and uh that's that's what i have
to say about that yeah these are all
fantastic insights this is great advice
um in the spirit of keeping things fresh
and lively
and you know again not succumbing to
zoom fatigue
i want to take a few minutes now and do
a full group sort of lightning round
um so we'll do two minutes roughly each
and i'd like you all to tell us what is
one key
piece of advice or sort of pearl of
wisdom that you would give to
prospective competitors in this
competition let's go with elements
okay i can start um so for me the one
key piece of advice
would be forming a team that shares the
same vision and the same values as you
do
i think the team defines the culture of
the startup and that's why working with
people whose beliefs and whose values
aligning to yours
are is so important to make your
adventures successful
and i mean successful not only in terms
of launching and
raising capital but also successful at a
personal level
i think um meaning that uh something
that is meaningful to you
and that you believe is adding value to
society
so i think that would be oh and someone
also someone who's
um who you enjoy working with because
you're going to spend a lot of time with
them
i think that would be mine
yeah absolutely i obviously i agree with
all that
um my advice again we're very early in
on
maria and i are early and so maybe don't
put too much stock in this but
this is similar to jonathan's point
which is you you kind of can't be
precious with your idea or what you're
developing
and my advice would be to test the thing
as quickly as you can and as often as
you can
before maria and i even before we had a
name
before we had any we're having
conversations about venture
this startup that we were testing our
idea
on captive audiences like our peers in
the department of architecture
or junior high students from the
cambridge area that we volunteered to
quote unquote teach
and then we went and tested our
prototype curriculum on them
and every even it's like embarrassing
it's a little hard to put unfinished
messy work out into the world and be
judged but we found that number one we
gathered a ton of useful information
that we were
only going to gather by engaging with
real people
putting our product half baked as it was
in front of them
and the other thing that we realized is
that people were
incredibly forgiving and helpful the
moment that you explained
this is something i'm working on i value
your opinion
we're talking to you because you do have
valuable insight and perspective
that we want access to and we think this
project is important but we can't get
there without
feedback from people like you the moment
you say something like that people buy
in
they're forgiving that the thing is a
rough draft and
we found that from junior high school
students all the way up to
phd candidates in mit people were
willing to take their time
and engage with your prototype and give
you earnest feedback
so test test early test often get over
the kind of like
shyness of it and just see what people
think of what you're working on
i think that's a really important point
i think especially for a lot of creative
people
it's sort of the intersection of passion
and vocation
and that vulnerability can be really
difficult to overcome
but you've got to you know get out of
that comfort zone in order to thrive and
flourish in the way that you're hoping
to succeed
um so ellen same question
yeah i think if i was talking to myself
two years ago just starting out on this
i would remind myself that um
no matter the outcome of the competition
um
you're going to learn more about
yourself than maybe even you learn about
your venture in this process
um and that that is
a worthy venture if you will um i
i also think that it's an incredible
opportunity
to get outside of the walls of mit a
place that can often be
very claustrophobic and
inward looking we used it as an
opportunity to
to finally get to know neighbors that we
never interacted with when we
uh you know spent all of our time in
building seven in studios
um and so i would use it as an
opportunity
to get to know yourself better as a
human as somebody who's going to be
joining
the workforce as somebody who works with
others
no matter what happens on stage it is
it is um an incredible opportunity to
get to know yourself a little bit better
too
i really appreciate that answer because
we're really trying to facilitate
edification learning betterment for
everybody at all stages and
it you know it shouldn't be end game
driven i think the
the focus and the priority which is
becoming such a rich part of the mit
entrepreneurship
ecosystem is that there's a spirit of
you know inquisitiveness and learning
and that you know
regardless of who gets the great big
check at the end of the day
ultimately there should be value added
and mentorship for everybody
so um yes absolutely uh nier
your turn uh i'll use some of the things
that you mentioned i mean for me
the the check at the end is not what's
important entrepreneurship
it's it's a mindset and it's a way of
living so whether if you will succeed
this competition or no
it's tools that will serve you later on
in life and the other let's say that you
need to start at least nine companies
until you
succeed with the 10th so it's a long
it's a long game
entrepreneurship um having said that
it's super important to
to use speed you need to make as many
iteration as you can with a
very limited time that you have and
creatives i really love to
to work with creative there is one a
challenge often is that they are so
passionate about what they are doing
they are so focused on the product the
presentation of the service that they
forget there is a customer outside
so it's important to have a great a
product but make sure that you speak to
your customers and when you go to your
customers
don't search for the answer you want to
hear come open-minded be
active observer in order to be able to
really understand
what they are looking for sometimes they
don't know what they want until you show
it to them so
that's my takeaway
i really like that the the insights that
everybody seems to be sharing today
center around network partnerships
willingness to fail
willingness to learn so john do you have
any other follow-ups for that
yeah one of the things i'll say is like
um always keep
a really tight pulse on like
socio-economic political situations and
i mean in this case i think that
for myself and a lot of entrepreneurs
that i know kovid19
quickly had us pivot but we were in a
situation where we were kind of already
able to do that and some of the
technology projects that we were working
on for sort of two years out from now
we ended up being able to look at those
technologies and kind of like
use them find uses for them now where
they could provide
um assistance and help um in the
education realm and in some various
other
areas so yeah having a very strong pulse
on
sort of the adoption of technology
obviously is really important
but but especially just you know what's
going on in the world where are the
anxieties where are the problems that
can be solved and trying to find that
problem that
is kind of relatively new and doesn't
have solutions yet for
it but we can imagine will be in place
for at least the next
next decade um that's that's what i
would really try to focus on
i think it's very important what you
just said things like
ongoing viability and sustainability it
touches back on what ellen said about
thinking about transcending the bounds
of mit
when you're a member of you know the big
bad real world
you still want your venture to sustain
and thrive and
having that mindset that forward
thinking mindset i think is essential
toward ongoing
success toward forging deeper
partnerships getting more buy-in
and building your longevity so we've got
about five minutes left in the panel
if anybody has any other conversational
points or questions or tidbits or things
that you feel like offering please let
me know i
don't necessarily want to end early
because we have a break i would love to
keep the pace going and i know that we
have so many good ideas and
great brains in this room right now
oh it looks like we have a question from
ceta um
go for it hey folks thanks so much for
taking the time to
share your experiences it's so
inspirational and so energizing so i
love it
um my question is um as someone who who
has
done some venture stuff related um uh
things in the past but not not quite in
the arts space
i'm curious to understand your
perspectives on what what have you found
are
um unique barriers and roadblocks in
building
a startup in the art space um and how
did you or how did you advise your
mentees to overcome those barriers
it's for us the mentos
uh for for both mentors and and uh
founders i mean i'll tell you generally
i think that when you come to a new
space there
are no experts in the new by definition
if it's new
nobody can have experience in that so
don't let the fact that you are not
art history graduate or not an artist by
yourself
to stop you from trying to solve a
problem that you think exists obviously
as i will
keep going back to uh one of the things
i
insist on is make sure that you validate
there is a problem and make sure that
you speak
if you are not an artist by yourself
speak as many with many artists as
you can if you are not a technology
speak as many technologies as you can i
mean
that's how you also learn and what's
beautiful about the
entrepreneurship or at least what the
mindset you need to adopt when it comes
to entrepreneurship
sometimes you don't know and it's okay
it's part of the game but you can also
learn
all the information in the world is
accessible uh almost for free so there
are some things that you can do by
yourself
in order to close the gap that's
that's my perspective i always believe
in a very attractive approach
it's never about waiting for someone to
give it to you you need to be able to
step up to the game and start to
actually
yeah get comfortable with this comfort
because sometimes it's not comfortable
to go to people
and just that's my perspective i
definitely share that perspective
the the comfort zone thing it keeps
coming up as a
as a conversational point it's that
growth mindset is really important
and recognizing uh as stephen sondheim
says opportunity is not a lengthy
visitor
and you've sort of got to create your
own opportunities
do we have any other thoughts before we
take another bit of a
zoom stretch break
going once going twice
another thing learn from michael
entrepreneurs need to sell
immediately he told us that we will have
the boxes available by the end of the
season
so it's very important sales skills are
super super important as an entrepreneur
you
always always always sell so
kudos to market that immediately showed
us that
we need we can buy the product at the
end of the month
that was really important you know
turning around on a dime that agility
was one of the most impressive aspects i
almost said one of the most impressive
elements
of elements if you will um all right
so we're winding this down and um i'm
sure
theo and i would love to thank near and
john
ellen maria and michael you've all
offered some really fantastic
insights it's been a delight to speak
with all of you
and thank you all again so much